es ist eine bunte Truppe die auf dem Hof
von Nadja denisevic aus dem Auto
klettert junge Frauen die meisten aus
Kiew die in Lukas schiffka ihr
Wochenende verbringen und mit anpacken
beim Wiederaufbau kommt bringt eure
Sachen rein
versteht erstmal wird gefrühstückt nadja
hat aufgetischt die Avocados haben sie
mitgebracht für die Frauen ist Nadja zu
einer echten Anlaufstelle geworden
wenn wir müde sind dann können wir uns
hier erholen das hier ist ein normales
Dorfhaus und das ist cool denn es ist
etwas sehr heimisches sehr verwandtes
das ist cool
ist unsere Freundin sie ist die beste
sie ist unsere liebe Oma sozusagen
unsere liebevolle Großmutter
die Sympathie beruht auf Gegenseitigkeit
stolz erzählt Nadja den Frauen von den
neuen Kleidern die sie von Helfern
bekommen hat alles in ihrem Dorf läuft
weil Organisationen und frei willige vor
Ort sind sind
dankbar dass es solche jungen Leute gibt
die unserem Dorf helfen es wird
restauriert und wieder aufgebaut
das Leben soll weitergehen in lukasche
deshalb sind die Frauen da sie sind
it-expertinnen oder Beamtinnen Häuser
gebaut haben sie vorher noch nie
sehr schön dies ist mein erstes mal mein
erster Versuch es ist interessant zu
versuchen das Material zu fühlen ich
würde nicht sagen dass es beängstigt ist
nein es ist interessant
wenn man alles versteht ist es nicht
schwierig aber wir verstehen nichts
unser bauschef hilft uns aber manchmal
ist es schwierig momentan
immer noch denn das hier ist schon das
vierte Haus dass die Frauen in Luca
schiffgar bauen das Geld kommt aus
internationalen Spenden
der Krieg ist noch nicht vorbei daran
werden Sie in Lukas schiffgar täglich
erinnert
450 Menschen leben in dem kleinen Dorf
zwei Stunden nördlich von Kiew die
Russen sind vor gut einem Jahr abgezogen
geblieben sind Zerstörung Chaos Leid
Menschen die mit dem Erlebten fertig
werden müssen
der kleine Hof von Nadja denisevic liegt
mitten im Dorf am 9 März standen die
Russen auch vor ihrer Tür
dann kam sie mit Maschinengewehren zu
uns wer ist im Haus fragen Sie die Oma
sie ist schon 96 Jahre alt ich habe sie
nicht aus dem Haus geholt ich war immer
bei ihr und die Kinder und alle anderen
die gingen in den Keller sie haben alle
rausgeholt und auf die Knie gezwungen
auch auf dem Hof sie trauen sich drei
Wochen lang nicht aus dem Keller weil
die Russen in Lukas Schiffer mit
brutaler Gewalt gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung Vorgehen elf Menschen
töten
dort haben sie eine junge Familie
erschossen die im Auto unterwegs war
eine Frau ihren Mann und Bruder und ihr
zweijähriges Kind die Russen haben das
Auto mit dem Panzer beschossen alle
waren tot
auf der frauenbaustelle steht ein
Ingenieur mit Rat und Tat zur Seite er
ist der einzige Mann den Frauen geht es
um so viel mehr als reiner Arbeit
Solidarität ist das was ihr Land gerade
zusammenhält
erstens kann ich nicht wegbleiben
zweitens komme ich aus dem Bezirk
kubiansk das ist ein ehemals besetztes
Gebiet es gibt dort viele zerstörte
Gebäude
ich glaube daran dass wenn ich hier ein
Haus wieder aufbaue jemand anderes ist
dort für mich machen wird das ist Karma
Karma die Straße runter zeigt uns Nadja
denisevic eines der Häuser das schon
fertig ist fast die Außenwände stehen
das Dach ist dicht aber drinnen ist
vieles noch zu tun den Innenausbau
übernimmt Familie Forster selbst bei
aller Vorfreude das hier bald vieles
schöner sein wird als vorher die Sorge
dass der Krieg zurückkommen könnte haben
sie schon
ich habe Angst aber wir müssen leben
fremde wollen uns nicht im Haus haben
der braucht in meine Familie niemand
braucht uns aber wir müssen leben ich
habe keinen Platz wo ich die Kinder
unterbringen kann ich kann ihnen doch
nicht sagen Kinder es ist Krieg also
lasst uns weiter im Keller leben wir
waren dort 21 nein 24 Tage
auch Nadja weiß dass ihrem Ort dem
ganzen Land noch schwere Zeiten
bevorstehen
[Musik]
alle Menschen helfen uns ich denke das
wichtigste ist der Sieg sobald er da ist
werden die Menschen motiviert sein um
etwas aufzubauen die Leute machen ja was
aber es gibt ständig Luftalarm man sagt
dass Lukaschenko Atomwaffen in Belarus
stationieren will und was Gott was als
nächstes passieren wird
die Frauen auf der Baustelle wollen
lieber nach vorne schauen neu anfangen
voller Optimismus
wir haben die Wahl entweder das Land zu
verlassen oder hier waren Wiederaufbau
zu helfen und ist zu einem Ort zu machen
wo man selbst lieben möchte mit den
eigenen Kindern
Julia und Aldi anderen bauen an der
Zukunft selbst die Störche sind wieder
zurückgekommen nach lukasche
der Hoffnung